je
ce domaine tel qu'on le voit aujourd'hui
n'a rien à voir avec celui qu'ont connu
madame de maintenon et le roi soleil
au 19e siècle donc c'est paul de
noailles qui va re décorer tout
l'extérieur du château avec le style
néogothique de l'époque et du coup cette
façade là qu'on voit en fait c'est une
façade qui a été collée sur l'ancienne
façade
si les murs extérieurs sont récents
l'ensemble nécessite un entretien et une
vigilance accrue
chaque jour l'émission de frédéric
change ratisser faire des petits travaux
électriques de la menuiserie ou encore
faire monter tours de rond voire
l'extérieur s'il n'ya pas d'étude qui
sont tombés s'il y a pas un objet qui
peut être dangereux justement pour le
public ça se peut voyez si on voit comme
je vous dis une tuile grand suspens
frédéric doit aussi s'assurer que des
petits déchets ne traîne pas dans le
jardin ou au bord de la rivière qui
arrose le château ça ces petites choses
qu'on ramasse parce que comme comme le
soir quand le public est parti il ya les
signes qui reviennent il ya des
bernaches il ya aussi des canards donc
pas pour éviter qu'ils les avale tout
tout tout simplement un geste pour
préserver la nature mais aussi la beauté
du site
une beauté harmonisé par le jardin à la
française dessiné par le célèbre
jardinier le nôtre pour madame de
maintenon cet écrin de symétrie n'existe
que depuis six ans il faut savoir que ce
jardin il avait été dit l'était dessinée
il était la bibliothèque nationale de
france
mais en fait il n'avait jamais été créée
donc en 2013
on décide de créer ce genre il faut
savoir que tout ce chemin a été tracé
entièrement la ficelle et au cordeau
comme étant le nom est exactement pareil
si créer ce jardin fut un honneur
l'entretenir et fondamentale en plus de
la surveillance au quotidien ils sont
quatre au moment de la taille a
travaillé pendant un mois et demi sur
les vingt mille buts et sur la
soixantaine de topiaires ce qui est
important c'est qu'on taille à la
cisaille à main cisaille manuel d'accord
donc si on veut avoir une coupe nette
sur un végétal il faut toujours taillés
avec une cisaille et vous aurez beaucoup
moins de maladies qui va se développer
contrairement à un jardin à la française
classique celui ci se pare de fleurs d
le printemps avec toujours une touche de
bleu madame de maintenon disait toujours
si j'avais pu j'aurais tapisser le
château de bleu donc pour faire un clin
d'oeil à madame de maintenon je plante
toujours double long de la rivière
là on a mis des myosotis bleus qui sont
plantés ici et l'été nous plantons des
sauges mystique bleus aussi donc a
toujours une couleur bleue vanhamme de
mcdo 15000 tulipes ont aussi été
plantées pourraient clore fin avril et
former un tableau de couleur sans égal
un événement annuel qui porte le doux
nom de tulipes yade
[Musique]